hello my name is Steve Kaufman I am the
president of the linguist Institute and
Link I speak 10 languages I consider
myself a linguist in the sense that a
linguist is someone who enjoys speaking
more than one language I even wrote a
book called the way of the linguist do
you want to learn another language why
not try to learn like a child a child
doesn't study rules of grammar a child
listens and by listening for a year and
a half or two years the child learns
naturally learns words and phrases and
when the child is ready and feels
confident the child starts to use these
words and phrases to speak you can do
the same but you can do better because
as an adult you have many words in your
own language you as an adult can read
and furthermore as an adult you can use
link at link you will find a great
variety of content items to listen to
and read if you are a beginner you will
have you will choose short pieces that
are easy and you will listen to the many
many many times and read and when you
read you will save words and phrases to
a personal database and then you'll be
able to review these words and phrases
using links many functions if you are
more advanced you needn't listen to the
same content so many times and you can
continually choose new and interesting
content to learn from saving words and
phrases and increasing your vocabulary
soon you will feel confident enough to
speak and you'll want to speak to our
native speaker tutors or you will want
to submit writing for correction there
are many other functions that link
please come to link I'm waiting for you
there it's both enjoyable and efficient
and I know that at link you too will
become a linguist thank you jajaja
washer Steve Kaufman was sure the
linguist institute link the
transfer what we do sure Jonah yeah
she'll ever sure when you'd some young
sure she your realm so if somebody
ahhhhh [ __ ] what you were my woman to a
call wafaa day but all the swedish your
heart battalion should show her tight
[ __ ] surge the movie the show oh she she
Jake Owen for greater cajole shooting
king betta Oceana Naval John Luther King
turned on tunnel she waits and daughter
sue sue sue D'Arnot I debajo de girona
da caixa la tarea croatia the fish are
quite adore wait on Daria Indians I'd
surgeon who you talk to iono darlin
cashew cancel mahesana don cornelio
linked you and she she she die linke
acquainted of her to a boot on shredding
De Niro accreting Eureka Troodon render
your puppies are your gender turn the
Vigilant under new info doctrine booty
come as a country home Dawson shall she
a [ __ ] at services Regina Odisha college
initiation mental conditions are come
daughter tap-dancing to label young king
her cut her Jersey its away nominee
civilian gee golly home Yahoo Yahoo
Yahoo woman dirty drama cha haw haw
Regina Sheeran John random issue it's a
link Johan dejando sharing in the father
was funny women like dolly parton cinema
chi minh con una caja says hola so Steve
Kaufman from the Lord a presidente they
link a the linguist institute
yo hablo de idiomas yo es Tito libro
sobre como se debe aprender y do más
para me la mejor manera este aprender
como los ninos aprenden su primer y
glioma los ninos non estudian grammatica
los ninos escucha y escuchen un
contenido bastante limitado pero
escuchar muchas veces y después de una o
dos anos y los ninos in Plzen habla en
su yoma bueno tu puede puedes hacer lo
mismo pero tu puedes hacer lo más rápido
y mejor que los ninos porque tu yeah oh
no face muchas palabras en su propio
aloma y tambien tu sabes de ayer y tu
puedes tellez r/s sistema linka en el
link de tu vas a encontrar muchos muchos
contenidos si tu eres 70 PR teh puedes
tienes que escuchar y cosas ciencias
pero muchas veces una otra vez y know
for meant a escuchar pero tambien de
ayer y y salvar palabras y frases
enteras hablar a las fan Sione's das
cancion x KY a link para ayudarte
aprender esas palabras y frases see y tu
tienes ya una Verma's auto idioma que
estas estudiando puede escoger dealt
rose la gran cantidad de de contenidos
que tenemos alica y una ver que que tu
tienes la con voz a la conciencia de
hablar en este como puedes cuidas deja
hablar con nuestros sir two tours online
an linea y tambien astre beer y so mejor
que estos hacer por heroes poor
a link essence tema muy a durable here
because Joe espero aquí a link hey hasta
luego graphics Bonzo lapel Steve Kaufman
just be Prezi down the linguist
institute a link the party lon j three
hundy hyssop and languished the
maravilla language second Ken Kesey
parle pas cool on the Crocker beaucoup
the person to lay upon a pally beaucoup
the longer cuyama the monavie full serv
1 upon coming off ha and I'm from the
papa they regular the Khmer enough on a
good on Akutan elecom demo it is
expression a [ __ ] non-farm a prayer is a
confirm from commence an increasing simo
SSX person who upon a group of FL mm
shows me vocally firm you busker an
adult a dejar beaucoup de mo da sahab
holland a pedo CMO another silly it was
emo and a dude purchase a link a link
Popovich Raziel to continue the
continued he was a TS series at davita
Buzzelli a cote de contenidos a brave
face on Eva's a lazy cote boku boku for
constantly prance feet are so God a
lame-o Ella's expression Julia Palmer
sleep over it is elli foxx yonder link
pour upon same OS X says expression been
faso agreeable fe cos cos epidermis a
capable one day cutie Oh Todd avoir une
important a photo Vishwa Z beaucoup de
cotton key goes on Tara's beato who's
Alice RTO like oh she owns the rapper
they have a computer yeah the cement the
text whoever revision learn a dog a link
set a fire set attica's sfiv pc
avago si vous pouvez Daphne language
ragusa Tom a link